I talk about in the my manual and I talk
about a lot actually when I visit
schools and universities and I've had
great feedback from this and it's a
great way to work out what normal is for
people you know around you and also get
you to reflect on your own normal and
it's called the traffic light Theory so
say we're sat here now we've got
croissants here we could be having a
lovely lunch together we could have our
children around the table and we'd go
around we'd say red Amber or green how
you're feeling today rad being bad you
get the idea now if I said that I was
Amber every day and I wasn't quite
feeling great but I wasn't terrible and
I was able just to articulate a few
reasons why like maybe every day the
similar stress or pressure was I was
facing maybe I just can't get quite on
top of my sleep it allows you and as
that person to learn about why they
might feel a certain way also allows the
people around you to learn what's normal
for them but then all of a sudden if
this person that was maybe green a lot
of the time suddenly becomes red maybe
three or four days in a row it makes you
go well hang on what's happened
Something's Happened Here that's changed
and the great thing is about having
going around in a circle around the
table and using this is that you all
learn from each other as to what things
actually make up good mental health
versus what might drag your mental
health down and so I think it's a really
it's a really powerful tool to use to
learn about your own normal and other
people's normals and that's why you know
a lot of this stuff I mean how long does
it take to sit around a dinner table and
do that traffic like there a few moments
yeah it was actually used
um in the pandemic by a lot of intensive
care nurses
um I believe one of the ones I heard was
UCL and they were using at the start of
end of the start and end of the Handover
shifts to basically identify nurses that
were struggling that were burnt out so
the senior management senior matrons
could focus their support on those that
are saying I'm red I've been working
five days in a row I'm knackered and so
on and it allows that early
identification I think that's one of the
biggest things when we go back to like
why is mental health food badly why do
we have such high suicide rates
particularly amongst men it's because I
think in certain subsections of society
we're not that great at like recognizing
our own struggles and acting upon them
all the struggles of other others and
when you talk about men's mental health
I mean why Iron Man up to 10 times more
like to take their own life than a woman
well you know is that because the
genetics is it the testosterone level
men and women are actually incredibly
similar there are slight variations in
our makeup I mean when you look at the
grand scheme of extreme of it we're
actually incredibly similar there are
slight differences most of the theory
around why it's so much higher in men
comes from the way that we've brought
men up to be if you've grown up with man
up grow some balls don't be a girl and
all these kind of harmful things is it a
surprise that when we've been teaching
men to be tough and speaking and sharing
is emasculating when they're at the
point of their weakness how are they
going to do what's most unnatural to
them and for them so it's it's so
important that we do these things and we
embed these kind of techniques into
family and into the into family dynamic
because it teaches us new law it teaches
her own normal it means that we can talk
about things when things are abnormal
it's like in the hospital isn't that you
know um the most dangerous scenario is
when you've got a team that isn't
communicating hating to each other when
someone is aware of something and
there's a patient they're worried about
they're afraid to talk out and it's very
similar in mental health in a way just
keep quiet keep quiet keep quiet and
eventually this problem becomes so big
it spills over you've got a cardiac
arrest on the ward and everyone goes
yeah but the sodium's been this high for
three days why didn't you say anything
because you were stressed because the
feedback I mean I've done so many uh
talks and I've done I've visited schools
from Scotland all the way up to the
North Coast of Scotland uh down to the
south coast of this country island Wales
ever at universities as well and it's
been one of the most popular things I've
suggested for families workplaces small
teams it's it's great it works so well
hey friends thank you so much for
watching if you enjoyed this clip then
click here for the full unedited episode
and if you like that then do please
consider subscribing to the channel it
means a lot thank you so much and have a
great day bye